this time on Bandit Patrol oh good grief
an orphan baby raccoon
adjust to a new space can you see an
injured possum yeah I know doesn't
appreciate the free health can you be
nice for once and a red-tailed hawk oh
no gets all up in a grill oh honey
thank you
[Music]
a new day means a fresh start in Western
Kentucky hey skunkers
get this little tiny one but not for
licensed Wildlife rehabilitator
Bridgette Williams and the recent
arrival of very smelly skunk kids
I just received a group of baby skunks
covered in their feces and urine messy
skunkers I'm also checking for any other
parasites or anything out of the
ordinary
did I mention that I love skunks
there you go
clean a skunk around
I do not bathe skunks unless they come
in really messy it strips the natural
oil from their fur which they need so
the more I Bae the less oil they have
cute as can be
so tiny
[Music]
little skunk burrito
and I love him
hello
oh my gosh okay I would just try to get
them in a box okay and where are you
located I'll just head out right now all
right thanks bye-bye I just received a
phone call regarding a baby raccoon
found in the middle of a road the baby
raccoon was found late last night so
Brigette must act fast I'm not sure if
this raccoon is sick was searching for
food or if it had got nicked by a car
I'm just not sure what type of condition
this little guy is going to be in
hey there how's it going I'm Brett with
Second Chances Wildlife Center nice to
meet you well thanks for calling thank
you
he is Tiny this raccoon is very small I
would say that he is only a few weeks
old and he was just randomly found in
the middle of the road he's in the
middle of the road just this little
singular okay he looked like a dead
squirrel yeah and then I stopped and he
was like wiggling so I put a sweatshirt
around him and I grabbed him well good
eyes yeah
very little okay okay kept squirming
yeah oh poor little booze
foreign
anytime just let me know oh well thank
you so much
he's crying for Mom
back at her Center Bridgette Works fast
to gather supplies for the little
raccoon the first thing I'm going to do
with this baby raccoon is to rehydrate
him I'm going to get this guy some oral
electrolytes I'm gonna warm this up
and then I'm gonna have to find a tube
for him
I don't waste any time here
mother raccoons typically feed their
babies about five times a day and
Brigette can't know for sure when this
little raccoon last ate a full meal
[Music]
is going to be
getting him to sit still while I give it
to him
when raccoons first come in they're not
a huge fan of the baby bottle it's not
Mom it's different milk coming it's just
a different feel altogether so what
makes life easier and a lot less
stressful for me and the raccoon is if
we just go ahead and Tube feed them
oh I know it's terrible it's terrible
no I'm sorry baby
I can only imagine what's going through
this little guy's head
almost done
there you go good job baby sorry I had
to do that
this should be kicking in and he
shouldn't feel better pretty soon
Brigette now must tend to the raccoon's
physical injury
boo what happened to your lips
looks like he's just lost a thin layer
of skin right there I'm not sure if that
was from the road I don't see any gravel
in there but I'm definitely going to
need to clean that
I need to put some ointment
all right little buddy let's get you an
incubator with some space
[Music]
have your room now
the reason why I just put this little
raccoon in the incubator is because he's
just too small to maintain his own body
temperature
the temperature in here and the soft
materials around him will only de-stress
in a little bit
and that's definitely what we want to do
I will continue to keep that on him
in Owensboro licensed Wildlife
rehabilitator Kristen Allen is dealing
with her own orphans an adorable herd of
hungry fawns hey guys I brought you some
fresh branches
are you excited
I cut fresh branches for them each day
because it's really important that they
know what they're going to eat out in
the wild and they start eating what
they're going to eat we worked hard
cutting those branches
get over there and eat
[Music]
I know I've been sweating everybody
wants the salt don't they it's so hot in
Kentucky and when we sweat The Fawns
love to lick the salt off salt is one of
those essential minerals that they need
they use it to its potential
they get all their salt from me huh it
kind of melts your heart but then you go
it's not looking because it likes me
it's looking because it wants my salt
I know I'm gonna have to get out of here
so I get assault away from you so you
eat the leaves
[Music]
see you in a little while
[Music]
Adrian you want to help me over here
juvenile possum
he says I got attacked by a cat
before long Kristen is on to a new furry
resident
a scared animal attack Survivor
hi there buddy
he says I don't like you yeah
all right let's see here
it looks kind of swollen compared to the
other one it is really swollen isn't it
in the wrist look at that skin
it's your little heart look at all that
skin you lost I just see exposed tendons
and muscles and the skin is just all
pulled back let me see if it's broken
oh wait a second
as I'm moving this Possum's arm I hear
bone grinding on bone and it's like oh I
know that there's a break there
it's really important that I set this
bone correctly in the wild a possum
can't really survive on three legs they
use all four legs to climb they use four
legs to run so they can get away from
predators unless you're a little hard
I'm just gonna clean it just a little
bit this is just a little natural
antibiotic ointment I know I know I'm
sorry
so I'm going to show you all 50 of my
teeth
opossums have more teeth than any other
land mammal in North America
you're a big tough guy aren't you not
tough enough for a cat though a lot of
people do not like possums but what is
not to love about a possum they eat
ticks they eat dead things which keeps
disease down and that cute little face
that cute little adorable face how can
you not love a possum
I'm gonna have a little cast
but the good thing is that young animals
a lot of times you can line that bone up
perfectly stabilize it and they heal
he says gosh dagnabbit lady
so we're just gonna have to tape it to
his fur
are you guarding his mouth he's actually
just kind of playing dead now playing
possum are you buying possum it didn't
work for the cat tonight
possums they kind of faint they secrete
things from the rectum and from their
mouth and what they're wanting to do is
say hey you know what you really don't
want to eat me because I smell nasty and
disgusting and a lot of times it works
[Music]
are we naming Lionel Lionel
with that
oh look at you
come back before you look
all right buddy the only reason I'm
putting him in something this small is
that I don't want him to move around
that arm's broke and I want it to stay
stable so if that leg doesn't heal
properly there's no way he can return
back out in the wild again all right
thanks babe
[Music]
it's lunch time
perfect
[Music]
oh I see you putting a tail up
it's been three days since the orphaned
raccoon found on the road has been in
brigette's care he is getting full force
formula
oh good grief
oh good grief
it's on his blankets is all over the
wall
last night I noticed that his nose was
bleeding just a tiny bit so there are a
little cloth blanket bumper pads all
over it to prevent this and evidently
didn't quite prevent it
wow
it looks like he has been bleeding for
quite some time quite a bit oh my gosh
I'm gonna turn them so I can see oh it
is his nose
my guess is that he's he's pretty much
rubbing it raw
looks like it's a surface nose blade
which ideally I would just kind of dab
it put a Band-Aid on it and go on for
obvious reasons I cannot bandage the
raccoon's nose he would not be able to
breathe
I need to make sure this does not
continue to happen he can't afford a lot
of blood loss
what am I gonna do for you little one
I know what I can do I want to make
everything collar
the cone
[Music]
you might not love it but it's going to
prevent this from happening over and
over
let me look around and see what I have
an e-collar basically is a cone shape
that is designed for an animal's
protection so they either can stay away
from Stitches anywhere on their body in
this particular case I'm hoping that
he's not going to continue to rub his
nose up against the incubator
I know what I can use
I'm going to get a cup and I'm going to
cut the inside of the cup
sometimes you have to be really creative
when you're rehabbing
these little guys aren't always the
largest of animals so what is made for
cats and dogs do not always work for
raccoons or opossums or bats
raccoons are very very cute they are fun
to watch they are so smart and they get
into everything
let's
let's Scouts
foreign
[Music]
I can only imagine what's going through
this raccoon's head
how's he look
look
all right little one
he can still breathe he can still cry he
can still move around
it's going to be livable
[Music]
oh little booth
it's been three weeks since Lionel the
Possum's leg had been broken in a
vicious cat attack right well I know you
ready to eat amazing
he's a stubborn patient and it could be
to his own danger so I go over to
Lionel's cage and he is sitting in the
corner without his cast on a little cast
is laying over on one side Lionel's in
the corner on the other side just
hissing at me I think he's saying I got
my cast off
[Music]
all right okay Cranky Pants come here I
know I know I'm trying to help you and
you're trying to bite
[Music]
when Lionel came in the skin was totally
torn up and the Cat broke the bone in
his leg
[Music]
rude you're just a little possum I've
ever dealt with
you're drooling on me oh and you're
pooping on me seriously
I bring you food you give me poop and
drool doesn't seem like a fair trade
there but
even though Lionel has pooped on me time
after time I love this little guy
you know I really think that bone has
fused back together there
which is a good thing for you the leg
looks really good but we're going to do
a little test to see if it can bear
weight
if he walks really well I'm going to put
him in an outdoor enclosure get him used
to being outside again I'm going to put
food in front of Lionel when I put him
on the table to see how he can walk
because Lionel never turns down a free
meal
all right let's see what you can do
buckaroo
I know you're gonna turn around and bite
me
oh look at you
oh yeah look all right go ahead you can
do it you can go get your food
using those all four legs
yeah
last time you were on here you were
dragging those legs okay all right okay
all right so I put him down on the table
and oh my gosh he's like and he runs and
I'm just like okay we're using that leg
that's good that's a good sign but back
in your cage you go
don't be mad this is a big step for
Lionel Lionel's walking really well but
that's just half the battle put your
little tail out he's got to show me that
he can climb
you're such a sweet angel
[Music]
oh my word you are a mess in here
get too big for that incubator
the dehydrated raccoon has been warming
up to Brigette for three weeks and now
he's cone free this little guy had a
nose issue
that he kept bleeding and bleeding okay
just eat just eat
well the good news is this little
raccoon's lip and nose have healed
wonderfully but I had been watching him
and I do think he has some type of
visual impairment
this poor little raccoon just cannot
seem to catch a break
he's not really responding to my hands I
think he's just looking around for his
food at the moment
[Music]
not even flinching
his eyes are not looking at me directly
they're going above my head normally a
raccoon will make direct eye contact
with you
the main thing that's going to be so
important to figure out if he's
definitely blind or has limited sight is
simply observing him over time
that's it it's it's gone it's gone
no can you see
can you just tell me
there is just a million reasons why this
little raccoon could be blind it could
be Health from the get-go he could just
have some type of congenital disease I
really don't know the reasoning
he's constantly looking up
I'm not sure if he's seeing light or
just trying to figure out what's going
on
if a raccoon is blind it simply is not
going to be able to survive in the wild
sometimes if animals do not see
adequately at first with good health and
good environment their site can come
back enough to be released that's my
hope for this baby raccoon
[Music]
I think that he scratched my bracelet
off I think all this little guy needs is
summertime
your baby
over two hours Southwest of Louisville
another rehabber is on the road for an
urgent rescue
I'm almost to Hanson now so I'll be
there here in about 20 minutes
I got a call this morning a guy was on
his way to work there was a hawk that
was coming out of a ditch he hit it
he just thought he killed it but then
when he got to work the hawk was still
there and it was still alive
in dire situations like this we're all
trained to do immediate triage on these
animals and birds of prey
ah there he is
hey hey my name's Nikki I'm Chris good
oh no
[Music]
oh no
the bird of prey is a mature red-tailed
hawk at least two years old
I was uh coming into work today and uh
this red tail hawk appeared out of the
ditch on me like that I was on the
highway so it was 55 mile an hour at
least I had about enough time to let off
the accelerator and
I hit it oh honey
that's the most he's moved since he's
been here first of all I knew it was
going to be bad because it was stuck in
the grill but when I got here and put my
eyes on it that was absolutely insane it
was the worst thing I've ever seen as
far as like just traumatic a registered
nurse Nikki knows how to keep her cool
and provide care in extreme situations
all right
can you pop the hood yes ma'am
honestly the only words that come into
my mind was holy fruit basket what in
the world am I looking at I've never
seen a grill smashed in from you know a
bird of prey like this and I knew it was
going to be torturous to get him out let
me grab a hold of him he's got blood
coming out of his mouth I'm sorry I'm
sorry all right go ahead
you can go ahead and try to get that
open I am so sorry honey
let me get the latch yeah if you can get
the latch
right now my biggest concern is a any
broken bones and then B he has got blood
in his mouth I don't know if it was
where he picked up you know his you know
supper or if it's his own blood
and if this is already broke can we
break through that it's just a new grill
that's all okay all right if we can
break that part I need to get him out I
am so sorry
all right
can you break this part off this here
bring it straight up perfect
give me break this piece dude if you if
you don't mind
oh oh okay
all right all right you have to let go
and you're not gonna Glory
one false move here and Nikki could do
irreparable damage to the Hawk's wing
this is not someone's not stuff okay
come on
all right love
you are beautiful but you
he got this foot caught up underneath
there in between those two little pieces
right there this was stuck up underneath
there and I don't know if he did just to
grab a hold of right
or
I'm glad to see him out hi gorgeous
these Hawks are absolutely beautiful
they're very large birds their wingspan
can actually get up to four feet I
literally think that he was holding on
for dear life now I'm not saying there's
not something broke right the hawk is
free from the truck but he's not out of
the woods yet he does have blood come
out of his mouth blood in the Hawk's
mouth can be a sign of internal injuries
I'm hoping that he just literally got
kind of in there and was too scared to
let go yeah without an extra pair of
hands I don't really want to mess with
his wings
so would you do me a huge favor I have a
crate in the back yeah I want to set it
on the tailgate or would it be yeah that
would be great
it's one Wild Ride he had yes it is
I don't want to injure his wings any
more than there it's better oh no he let
go oh here let go okay thank you so much
thank you for coming you did awesome
thank you
like I said I didn't want to see him
no he didn't have to I work out here in
the end my fear is always hitting a deer
that's that's been my biggest fear for
the three years I've worked here
different from a lot of streams if I
thought I'd hit a hawk
this bird he's a lot better shape than I
thought on the outside I don't know what
type of internal injuries he busted the
crap out of the guy's Grill
blows my mind that he was not you know
just killed instantly
Nikki is not licensed to rehab Raptors
so she quickly transfers the hawk to
those who can
I'm not called Kristen and Grant Allen
this guy needs to be over there with
them as soon as possible
I guess hey how are you yeah that was
horrendous it really was
as I hear that this truck was going over
50 miles an hour and it hit this Hawk
I'm thinking he's got to have broken
bones something's got to be wrong with
it sure red tail yeah
it was just the craziest thing
you have a no good very bad day it looks
like this one was the one in the car
yeah yes this one was the one that was
up in smashed in this one's below
there's something wrong with the
shoulder
I can't figure out if it's just
dislocated
or
I'm not sure that there's
feel this right here and I feel just
like this
the right wing sticking probably two two
and a half inches higher than the left
lean
oh that's about the place I think I
think you did too there you go
you did are you kidding me did you hear
it yes I heard it yeah I did too when
Grant gave that Wing a little twist and
that shoulder popped back into place I'm
like that boy really knows what he's
doing that was pretty awesome does that
feel better buddy much better
oh my gosh that's crazy okay so let's
make sure there's no broken bone
I can't believe when he moved that it
popped back in place that is
unbelievable that is crazy I heard it
yeah that was
yeah no it feels much better and it's
popped back in place now like it's it's
that full extension
like just kind of popping yeah it's
still it is kind of popping there a
little but
yes he's got some blood right there
lay someone open his mouth I can see it
straight again
he might have some head trauma
we're gonna have to get home the light
to check it out for sure
[Music]
look at you you are one lucky bird
that's all I have to say to you today
all right let's get you in the crate and
get you home we'll wrap your wing
all right here we go
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you let me
know how he does okay I will I will
[Music]
all right so I'm going to go ahead and
pull them out all right sounds good it's
taken all night in three animal
rehabbers to rescue a red-tailed hawk
and hit by a truck
he says I'm feeling better now that my
shoulder's back in place
what are you still sticking your tongue
out for huh
Grant said its dislocated shoulder but
he and Kristen must check him further
for unseen damage
talk right now
horrible I can't imagine getting hit by
a car driving a long way and getting
removed from the grill he's got to be in
pain he's got to be scared birds get hit
all the time it's because they have such
good binocular vision on what they're
grabbing and once they grab it and they
fly off they're probably still looking
down at the animal when they take back
off and that's how he probably got hit
poor little guy
how's that shoulder feel now does it
still feel good yeah the shoulder feels
good but I think that need to go ahead
and put the wrap on it like we thought
we should just that way we could keep it
in place let's give him some pain meds
really quick
Nikki had commented about blood
you're a little bit
it's right here where it's bleeding it's
like it's on top it's on the right if
there's blood coming out of the mouth of
a Raptor it can definitely be a sign of
internal injuries
same
oh yeah I think it's just maybe an
abrasion there yeah there's nothing we
can really do about that no it'll heal
the mouth heals quickly yeah you should
be good I can't believe he doesn't have
any other injuries
unbelievable
this retail Hawk is showing no obvious
signs of head trauma but that doesn't
mean that he doesn't have head trauma
this feels very threatened right now
when stressed red-tailed Hawks open
their mouths and pant we definitely need
to wrap his ween up Grant and I decided
that we should probably keep his wing
wrapped for about a week then we'll take
him to a Western Kentucky Raptor Center
right well I think we need to name him
lucky because he was yeah you can shake
your head because he was darn lucky to
have lived through that
aren't you I've dislocated my shoulder
and it doesn't feel good and once you
hold it in place for a long time it
heals back up he says I don't like my
wings I'll get him a mouse and it'll
make him happier this Hawk is very tough
and very lucky
[Music]
all right Lionel are you ready
step by step Lionel is strengthening his
little leg
when you're smiling at me again after
two weeks of walking Kristen wants to
kick his rehab up a notch I'm taking
Lionel to our second property today to
put him in an outdoor enclosure I know
he can walk really well I want to make
sure that he can use that leg to climb
though show me that you can use that leg
and you can be a wild possum again it'll
be a wild possum again
yeah I know you're mean enough that's
for sure
nothing's gonna mess with you in the
wild this move will give Lionel the
opportunity to scrounge for food he'd
normally eat in the wild and have the
space to behave like a possum
all right this is way bigger than your
enclosure at home way bigger
just wait till you see what I'm doing
for you
all kinds of old logs in here that have
bugs in them
I got all sorts of Wiggly squiggly
things from my little favorite possum
today like he's gonna find in the wild
to Cranky Pants I want you to go over
there and get it now I call him my
favorite he doesn't like me he doesn't
like me since day one but I'm okay with
that
would be nice for once once I made you a
special pie and you're still not gonna
be nice to me
does that smell good
all these smells that he's smelling are
things that he has smelled before but
it's been a little while since he
smelled it
show me what you can do I want you to
show me how you climb you do that show
me how you can climb will you I want to
see that paw work
see what you can do big boy
come on Lionel
Lionel
I'm so excited to see him climbing he's
grasping with that front left leg
he's totally using that foot
then when he gets to the top I have to
laugh because he's like a toddler he's
like okay now that I'm up here how to
get down
there you go
eventually he figured it out
where are you going huh
I hope you like your new home but it's
only temporary
next time I see you buddy I'm sending
you out in the wild
[Music]
oh God
come on we have fun stuff to do in
Louisville brigettes once dehydrated
raccoon has spent some time in a calm
safe space and is ready for his
follow-up eye exam right now I'm going
to do a little bit of testing just to
confirm I'm going to check his eyes the
light
I really really am hoping for some good
news
first thing I'm going to do is see if he
has any reaction
that one did
let's see I'm going to do that again
he's just gonna keep biting my finger
harder and harder until he thinks milk
is going to come out
all right I'm gonna check the right eye
a little flinch
and a little Flinch
his pupils are dilating
I think you can see a little bit
[Music]
I feel proud so this is great news I am
just thrilled that this little raccoon
will be able to be released back into
the wild the next step is for me to
place them in with other raccoons of
similar age and size so they can
eventually go back outside together
in a few weeks Brigette will move the
little raccoon and his new family into
an outdoor enclosure they will learn
climbing skills they'll Forge around for
food all these things are very very
critical in their survival once they get
back out into the wild this is awesome
it's been two
lucky the red-tailed hawk was hit by a
truck
shoulder on the mat it's time for him to
spread his wings
make sure
I love animals but I have a special
place in my heart for retail Hawk so I'm
really hoping this red tail hawk pulls
through for me
never had a raptor hit by a car before
and this kind of speed and survive
did you hear that
see that one Wing is still down
there are so many things that could be
wrong with this Hawk we know that he had
a dislocated shoulder and we popped that
back into place
so yeah I think it's fully healed but
sometimes it's not what you do see it's
what you don't see that you have to
worry about so it's taken to the center
and put him in the white flight cage
okay and see if he can fly let's just
take him there and see how he does
[Music]
I hope he does well
he's looking really good you ready bacon
but you don't know until you get them in
something bigger you just don't know how
they're going to do
or maybe he's just excited
foreign
so the next step is for lucky to show us
exactly what he can do
[Music]
watch out he bites
yeah so I think he's ready to see if he
can fly
but
the chest is popping I don't know what
it is it's just weird I heard it popping
when you laid him down earlier Raptors
are actually kind of tricky to rehab you
can't read their body language like you
do mammals that makes it much more
difficult
I don't know that he's using that foot
right now that he's put him up on this
branch and see what he does
you stand up come on quit pouting
the way that this red tail hawk is
standing is looking like there's
something wrong with it
look at the difference in this
he's standing bow-legged huh
we both kind of look at each other like
he's not sitting right he's not sitting
up tall like a red-tailed hawk should I
think it's his pelvis and maybe that's
why he's standing weird
foreign
he's worrying me look at him
huh
flew
I can't land
so I just feel around to see what
I want to feel around those legs
I'm feeling this back of this pelvis
right now and I don't feel anything at
all
so there's that Poppy noise that we said
we heard yeah but well do you just want
to take him to Dr kunzi and have an
X-ray done hopefully we'll go and have
an x-ray down and he'll say there's
nothing wrong he's just being a pouty
pants
the popping noise is just it just
bothers me I'm just lying
yeah you're gonna grab the crate
and take them to Dr Community to get an
x-ray to see what's up
[Music]
unfortunately lucky died before we could
ever get him to Dr kunzi's office
this is one of those things that are
it's a shock I'm like you think that you
you're you're on that road to recovery
that that you you've jumped through all
the hurdles that you needed to jump
through and then and the animal just
dies out of the blue
it's very heart-wrenching
it's not what you can see on the outside
it's what you can't see on the inside
makes a rehabbers drop really hard
really hard I couldn't have done
anything to help him and and it makes me
sad that he never made it back out in
the wild again
[Music]
Sunrise brings a new opportunity for
another animal
after several weeks of brushing up on
his outdoor possum skills Lionel is
ready for his return to the wild you
guys ready yep think he's ready oh yeah
I think he's been ready for a while
exactly
Lionel has definitely done a 180. he's
gone from this little poor thing that
could barely walk that climbing and
acting like a big mean old honorary
possum
all right Lionel where are you dude
[Music]
you are
it is a big day for you
come here handsome
[Music]
leave me alone
I mean Adrian Sophia and I are going to
take Lionel out to this beautiful wooded
area so he can be released this is the
day you've been waiting for since I got
you oh well he's
tailing dude
all right final call shotgun
I love having my daughters help me
rehabilitate Wildlife you know it's that
bond that we have some people take their
children shopping well I take my
children to pick up animals and save
them
all right this spot looks good up here
okay
look back here let's look down here on
this one
we'll just kind of open up his crate and
see if he'll go out on Zone I feel like
he will
okay Lionel
[Music]
let's go buddy
thank you
going buddy nope
I really thought as much as he disliked
me that he was just gonna take off
running
go why don't go
on go go go
here you go
this Rehabilitation process that we go
through this saving animals us impacting
the world I feel like I'm teaching them
far more here than I would at the mall
here he goes
look at the using that leg now
bye Lionel it's gonna be great yeah he
is by Lionel
in Louisville today's raccoon day
courgettes once visually impaired
raccoon has cleared all his hurdles
here's our little guy that came in with
all the issues
this little raccoon is ready for release
because he knows balance he's climbing
very very well come on
oh he outsmarted us he's healthy fur's
looking good eyes are clear there's just
no indication that says he needs to stay
back any longer
there is more than one day that I
thought to myself this point would never
come come on I know I know it's scary
but I never gave up
holy schmoly clearly the behavior that
all these raccoons exhibited says that
they are ready to return to the wild
I have an ideal location in mind that
has over 100 acres that's going to be
just great for them
tree for them it's so easy to climb lots
of little wedges in there
[Music]
okay we'll get them kind of face at the
tree area all right
okay here here baby it's okay he's like
what was I in
um
[Music]
yeah I know you're happy to get out of
there that's so sweet these guys appear
to be very curious about their new
surroundings
all right I'm gonna get this last one
out
even though I have grown to really like
this little raccoon I would be very sad
if he had to stay with me all right and
here you go come on
come on
it's your time little one
foreign
[Music]
there he goes there you go babies
this little raccoon's case is why I
rehabilitate wildlife
I am so glad that we spent the time and
efforts on his health
here he goes
keep going buddy
foreign
[Music]
until the next batch that's right
bye guys
love you
[Music]
[Music]